[Music]
in found you news I found John you are
found it found you you missed nobody who
knows why you a [ __ ] submitted by Meg my
stress hello a missing teen was found
with her best friend's dad in Mexico oh
let's explain that yeah question marks
there let's explain that I'm pretty sure
it happens a lot like then found what
they're best friends dad somewhere you
know do you have any friends like that
no I'm not good dad just like you know
showing people around educational field
trips remember you're supposed to
sympathize yeah I am we don't know we
don't know that we don't know the
situation it we got kidnapped or if he's
a pedophile we don't know any of those
things
yep so far all I know is I just jumped
the gun yeah but without the daughter
though well like his daughter in the
daughter already knows act like they've
the daughter that I've been a joshua
tree 20 times that but sara has never
been but what about the wife that's like
but man was found living as a roommate
with best friend's dad that's me where's
the friend he wasn't living there oh
yeah Jose did with my dad remember yep
no one called that we it all said that
is we no one would hard
why don't you write article yeah I'm
lazy it wasn't in Mexico might as well
because it was so I'm just lazy it was
an Omani in a pepto-bismol house yep
it's a pink house dad painted that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] like Homer Simpson donut
yeah yeah busy colorblind I hope I hope
so I hope so
if he's not that's even your horrible
teeth yeah let's just say he is yeah we
thought it was beige yeah all right so
this is Amy you and Kevin Esterly 16:45
why that will look like white bark no
one was slightly attracted smile like
water no why if Bart and Steve's made a
baby I'm like what Steve and then the
see she's 16 but I feel like Asians for
light with 1416 she's 16 looks 9 like 16
to 22 like 50 you're the same in the
same face she could pass for a 25 year
old or a 16 year old Asian girl yeah
yeah she looks like that hole yeah look
if you were like she's 29 I'd be like
yes so amy has been a family friend of
Kevin's family because Kevin has four
daughters so they met Amy through church
back when she was like perfect back when
she was seven or eight years old and so
they've been so they were in Mexico
giving blankets to people in the
mountains No so the dad knew this girl
when she was eight so yeah seven seven
Chris nice nice gotten great yes gross
yeah so that reminds me of a good old
Woody Allen I know right they loved
those young Asian girls yeah so since
Kevin has four daughters like they would
often invite Amy to their family
vacation so they would go out all the
time I was like family yeah yeah he
treated her as like the fifth daughter
that's disgusting that's right
with the oldest daughter but yeah so
apparently kevin and his wife had been
fighting for the past eight months
because things took a turn over the past
summer with Kevin and Amy to a point
where I like the mom was like you know
what's going on like I mean I don't know
the details but why are you always
tutoring Herman's intuition you keep
saying you [ __ ] do a Bible study but
why do you have to Bible study that
[ __ ] six p.m. till midnight
apparently let me smell your dick so
this dude was signing Amy out of school
about ten times from November to
February
oh [ __ ] are her parents so she has a mom
like her dad is out in China she since
she was a little girl her mom is here
and she has a she's a brother as well
but this dude was pretending to be her
stepdad signing her out of school and
the mom never knew but apparently the
wiseguy criminal the white bill
apparently the wife found out before the
mom you and that's why the wife was like
arguing what with the husband it's
forbidden love yeah it's just
and so they planned it together to leave
to Mexico agent my vote over and so they
were gone for twelve days he had gone on
vacation that's how that's what her face
is like she's stole money from her mom
he stole four thousand dollars from his
wife's account oh my god to Mexico
apparently he was like obsessed with her
what is oh and would she be attracted to
him I don't know daddy issues
Asian girls love white guys and girls
with absent fathers yep yeah she looks
happy in Mexico though best combination
Mexico I don't know
it'd be more rappers on the floor I
don't see the true or lady in the back
so he also rented an apartment four
blocks away from her home
and like that weird that's like where
they would you know him and his wife's
money to rent an apartment yeah and
apparently he was like his obsession
with Amy grew so much to the point where
it affected him with his job and like he
got who's been unemployed oh wow like
you needs help that's what happens when
you get yellow fever yeah you can't
control it yeah what's the what's the
reverse of daddy issues when it's the
older man that can't that gets obsessed
with like daughter issue yeah daughter
issues but it's like she's a teammate
it's like not a kid kid where they're
like but he's been scouting eight yeah
she was yeah that is that's the gross
that's the weird part
she looks like a little do you think is
one of those things not like a
voluptuous developed young lady that
looks like a woman yeah but a lot of
Asian women just stay kind of like with
the same like little girls that might be
the voluptuous version of Asian yeah
I've always had this idea in my head
that any any I mean I'm not trying to
sing all Asia white dudes out there but
like white dudes that like Asian girls
I'm always thinking like you gotta have
some sort of friends with this couple
that um the girl is Vietnamese and she's
tiny like like gotta be under five foot
like very tiny like looks like twelve
like when I went to Bali I got our pair
of pants and I said do you have like
pants for like a ten-year-old and they
fit perfectly on her yeah and she so she
looks like twelve but she's like
thirty-six and um and yeah and the dude
is like a tall white guy he's like six
foot two linkie like right and they want
to hold on to that teenage girl for
thirty years
yeah yeah yeah so Steve's always like
what you this should be illegal
that's dumb
weird I mean I think it could be more
like I don't I don't think it's so much
that I think it's more like Asian you
guys might disagree but they have more
of a like an inclusive like nurturing
nurturing take care of my man really
like Asian girls don't have that I mean
most Asian or so big white yes they're
tipping a little more submissive white
but not not in the way why do you think
I would a white girl you're like really
strict with their kids but they like
we'll have dinner ready like the hub
yeah I have dinner ready and stuff but
they look they're like they'll come down
on you yeah they're [ __ ] cold harder
crazy that's where I got that I feel
like that's the stereotype outside
that's what they look like is these like
docile quiet creatures but then when you
actually get with them they [ __ ] run
[ __ ] and they yell they [ __ ] you up it's
like I think that's why you see all
these old like like mixed couples and
then like the white dad is like defeated
yeah the Asian mom run [ __ ] yeah run
[ __ ] that's true that's so in this
couple like the girl is totally like
what did I get myself into
it's like [ __ ] but he's like like say
he's like very just goes along with
things you guys can be if you yes we
caught them in Mexico after there was an
Amber Alert [ __ ] he's like that's right
I landed that and that other cop is
posing like you know that pictures
getting it taken like let me let me look
a little more jazz he's he's flexing
yeah let me represent for who's ashamed
oh no you like proud had a file and what
yeah so as of now he's in Florida
pending extradition to Pennsylvania he
will be arraigned on if that felony
charge of interference of the custody of
a child and it's funny because they're
reporting that he's been calling his
wife non-stop but she's like [ __ ] you
Wow I'm how do you even break that to
the kids and how do the kids take it
like daddy ran away for the best yeah
that would be like the daughter of [ __ ]
yeah it'll be my friend man why are you
[ __ ] my daddy
that's like American Beauty oh yeah
Beauty that's an old-school man she said
it in the beginning to that this is like
a common thing
Stifler's mom American pop we've done a
JK story before well yeah yeah I'm never
here sorry guys hey late to the party no
you're good I think you have a normal
reaction we're all unfazed now another
one it's still shocking because it
shouldn't happen but it is but it's so
we're calling it makes you think about
how much more common it is then I mean
so is murder but it shouldn't happen
right yeah
[Music]